there was outrage at a hearing in Uvalde
Texas about last May's school shooting
parents and relatives of victims are
demanding that the head of the Texas
Department of Public Public Safety
resign for what happened that day but
yesterday he defended his agency's
response to the attack that killed 19
children and two teachers Janet shamlian
has that story
if you're a man of your word you'll
resign
we're not waiting any longer angry
families of Uvalde victims demanding the
resignation of Texas DPS director Steve
McCraw McCraw once vowed to step down if
his Department had any culpability in
the botched response one Trooper Juan
Maldonado was fired last week for his
inaction and others were under
investigation
Maldonado can be seen in this body cam
video obtained by a San Antonio news
station now this is so sad dude that he
shot kids other unidentified officers
can be heard contemplating their own
safety before entering the school with
the gunman inside
[Music]
I'm trying to get a clap in his in his
first public comments since June macaw
on Thursday was defiant DPS is an
institution
okay right now
is did not fail the community
plain and simple he refused to resign or
provide details on dps's internal review
of the Uvalde response our town is
divided Jesse Rizzo the uncle of Jackie
casares blame Macro for what he called
continued misinformation your officers
either lied to you
or you painted a picture that was
favorable to your department sir the
craw blamed local police in the days
after the massacre it was later revealed
of the 376th law enforcement officers
who responded 91 were DPS Troopers Red
Cross was the legal guardian of
ten-year-old uziah Garcia my son is dead
18 of his classmates are dead two
teachers are dead there's many more
wounded in everything but he's going to
make this that they're all going to do
this politically
lacrosse had the DPS investigation will
be complete by the end of the year but
the parents I talked to are not hopeful
that they'll have any more information
at that time it comes as the governor
just announced 15 million dollars for
the construction of a new Elementary
School in Uvalde that's because Rob
Elementary will be demolished Tony
people looking for a fresh start there
Janet thank you very much